i want to talk to some cubans
in a way it's this american dream that a
lot of people can't get
it's almost a little bit like traveling
to another country
a little bit what's it like being in the
state versus there
once you said something in english and
she didn't shut it off hola
is this the place would you consider
them patriotic towards the state what is
cuban style about this
salmon calamari lobster risotto you are
here because you are freedom socialism
system
destroys everything what is the progress
we mean by crazy like it's
like it's dangerous or if you aren't
home don't worry about it thank you
[Music]
good morning guys here in miami home to
so many of the world's cultures
today we're going to jump into the cuban
world
it's going to be a bit spontaneous don't
know what i'm getting into
i think you'll be surprised because i
think i'll be surprised
okay let's do this
[Music]
here we are hialeah and this is the
biggest cuban enclave outside of cuba
most people know of little havana
but i was told through some insider
knowledge that this is the place where
all the cubans are hello
hola is this the place bro
tell me about it
good food this place over here chico's
been here for a long time
so this is where most of the cubans are
right most of them
yeah schools you get the new school you
get everything here am i
am i in the right place in the right
place so have some good breakfast
definitely
right on brother thank you but should i
go here
yeah right there all right there we go
from the source this is the place
i'm gonna go into chicos
okay looks like an old school restaurant
hola
what are you looking for i'm looking for
like the center of hialeah
the center of hialeah yeah i want to
talk to some cubans
is a good place this is a good place to
talk to them you're from here
yeah i've been here since 1961. wow how
is it is it an interesting neighborhood
yeah i had no problem you know it's
because it's up and downs
yeah you know like everybody feels like
a good local neighborhood
oh yeah a few fast facts for you on
hialeah
before we walk around uh the population
is 224 thousand
so it's it's outside of miami it's right
outside of miami 224 thousand
uh 73 are cuban
and 96.3
speak spanish so i gotta i gotta pull
out my
spanish speaking skills that cuban feel
you know the old men playing chess
uh sitting around smoking cigars in a
park i haven't found it yet
don't know if it's gonna be out here
but i'm not giving up
it's not going to lie it's been hard
finding human beings around
but i just saw these kids and uh
[Music]
they're they got a mod shop you call
this a mod shop or what do you call it
all right you're from hialeah yeah
so what's what's it like guys what's it
like what do you mean by crazy like it's
like it's dangerous or it's dangerous
it's sometimes
it's dangerous but okay you're from
california you know that music
california
at carman have you seen those car meets
have they take over the line yeah yeah
okay okay we do something like that here
in high level we're we don't not we're
not involved in anything like that
saying it out loud we don't take our
cars there and i think we just watch on
the on the
on youtube we see them going around they
do them all over here hi elia they got
people with cameras
if you come out of your car and i got 11
around there tonight
tonight yeah tonight for sure you're
going to see that what about what about
the cop across the street is he
there is he cool they're cool they help
us out
they're cool so the neighborhood's safe
yeah yeah oh my god
if they talk bad about hialeah that's
how it would be really
cool it's like a nice neighborhood
yeah it feels that way so you're you're
all cuban like your parents are cuban
yeah i'm like you were born in cuba yeah
i got here
like 10 years no way yeah
you have no accent i do i don't barely
barely i can't even tell where'd you
come from in cuba
what's it like being in the states
versus there versus there
bro here's a lot of possibilities there
you know whatever you want to do you can
do it
over there is like limited you know
right cool like
you work for your over there you
work and they take away your stuff here
you
work and you get whatever you want
so you get to do what you want to do
obviously yeah i said i got out of
school and i was like i mean left my car
open changed something on and i did and
there it is running again a little
messed up in the front but
what's uh rompe corazones what does that
mean
i mean heartbreaker because they used to
have a bunch of hearts on the side
all right take them off and it was like
a bunch of broken hearts are you the
heart are you the heartbreaker
yeah my girlfriend left me so like i was
like heartbroken
yeah is to start my shoe business that's
my dream shoe business i like shoes
like custom shoes yeah like leather nice
shoes yeah
custom like italian stuff yeah
he likes every type of shoe you wear
yeah like jordan air max
97's we got you resell them
what are you rocking there i don't know
as well is why air
all right are they are these cool or no
vans i like that
for a 43 year old sort of cool
i was in cuba years ago i went there
yeah really
yeah really nice people the the
community for the hialeah
love america and respect america and
when you have any any you like war
everybody's celebration
everybody we are america why why do they
love america so much you think well we
love america we go
because we say we have freedom
when you have the freedom you've love it
when you don't have the freedom and you
have a restriction for your life and you
can dream
you know you say i hear because i am
i don't have a choice no no you are here
because you have freedom
you feel it here
i think many americans don't know this
well if they never left
if they never left the problem
too many people born you know an
american but
he never knows what is the freedom
right because he never lost the freedom
when you love something you miss and you
say
wow that's the difference
yeah that was the reason everybody like
could come to america
you think it's losing freedom at all or
no yeah here
a little bit yeah the problem is america
is not perfect
yeah yeah but you have opportunity for
change
in the other country you don't have a
chance
no opportunity for change
that's the difference because
you say hey i know the country had the
you know the gold
having oil having you know diamonds
have it everything and why is the people
who's poor why do people don't have a
school where the people don't have a job
what do people
die for hungry right
because it's the rich country ah because
it's not freedom
like venezuela they they have they also
have the oils exactly the venezuela
because i know how these periods about
the venice me neither but i know they
have the oil they just don't yeah
all right okay they have the oils yeah
these are rich
everything is disappeared because the
the system for the
social socialism system is
destroyed everything what is the
progress
destroy the lamb is here but he don't
want you plant
food in the lab plant i'm sorry plant
food and what
the food and the soil oh
yeah because you say well i know how do
you know the lion or have a soil
i can't put you know the bananas blend
with the bananas
or three for the orange no no no no
you have you know good but you know life
plan
the government say no
i want to plant you know the the lemon
tree no no no
no no no lemon tree because i say i
i order here boom you're not afraid
of thank you e o t e o
appreciate it some good old wisdom thank
you guys
love your neighborhood all right it's
cool thank you
bye-bye it's nice to hear from people
that
that have been on that journey that
understand things
i'd say better than most because they've
seen another
another system here we are el palacio de
los hugos
looks like a local food
outdoor dining
check it out
wow this place has got a lot going on
a little bit everything salmon calamari
lobster risotto
[Music]
i was in cuba many years ago and i had
cuban food but i don't remember so well
yeah that's it's much different over
there than it is over here much much
different
obviously we have much many more choices
than what they have
over there so i just met this guy carlos
and he's walking uh walking us through
the food situation
so this is all cuban right uh yeah most
of it is
most of it is cuban so this is like a
paella
spanish paella cuban style absolutely
absolutely
that looks good whatever that is like a
fish still
yeah that's grouper and tomato sauce
[Music]
and i'm buying this this is my treats
yes yes yes
yes carlos
some delicious grouper right cubans call
that cherna
and some mixed vegetables yeah okay
what's what is uh what is cuban style
about this
uh the tomato based sauce okay we use
that in a lot of uh
in a lot of our traditional cooking
there we go you guys don't really do
spicy food do you
no no that's uh that's more of mexican
mexican things mexicans love their spice
cubans
absolutely no worries we're lucky though
because
carlos agreed to go on a little walk
away from the noise
and he is the hialeah expert
because you're his you're a history
teacher yes sir you grew up here
absolutely okay so what's going on here
walk us through
what's the story of this neighborhood
the brief story let's say 1980
you have the mario boatlift in january
of 1980.
uh jimmy carter let a
big wave of cubans they waited on at the
marielle port
in cuba uh they waited for about a month
to depart okay so families left
miami uh in search of their families
they went back to cuba to pick them up
they were waiting there for weeks and
weeks and weeks and eventually
what happened was that fidel castro he
he said well if you want to take your
family member
you got to take x amount of people on
your boat so maybe your boat can handle
you know 10 people uh-huh well now you
had 50 60 100 people on the boat
and you were forced to take them so if
you wanted your family members you had
to take
all these other people who you did not
know and who were mostly criminals
so he had beat out the jails right the
emptied outs
uh all the uh the drug addicts yep uh
anybody who was
uh gay they were all
packed on the boat and sent out of the
country right the undesirables
as he called them right pretty smart
sending all the criminals out huh yeah
but the vast majority of cubans outside
of the country
live here in hialeah what are the jobs
here where are people working
so a lot of the factory jobs the
original inhabitants came here because
a lot of the factories in south florida
were located in hialeah
you know as uh industrial jobs
trade jobs a lot of factory jobs they
got shipped out of the united states to
places like china and indonesia
those shop those jobs have have left so
a lot of these people
you know they work jobs in corporate
america
they work jobs uh you know like any
other
uh american you know you got waiters and
waitresses
accountants yeah yeah that's what you
have you know in this area
so it's is it um i've seen a lot of
american flags so it's pretty
a pretty patriotic place i'm gathering
absolutely no i say that i don't see
anybody
coming in here i think a lot of them
were taken down
after the election yeah hialeah is
extremely conservative
okay you know i'm moderate myself but uh
hialeah
is uh one of the most conservative
cities in america
which uh has you know pretty much been
the same for them about the last 40
years
okay so my theory is people left for
communist country
not because things were great they came
here they could realize themselves they
could get a home
less things in their way right and so
the conservative
side of things
mirrors that better let's say yeah is
that
is that the point or what what why why
are they why are they so conservative
here or is it family values and
so yeah that has a lot to do with it
they left a communist regime
a very uh you know totalitarian
government with the with the dictator
and they wanted that freedom from the
conservative party
or the republican party here in the
united states
uh you know although this is a very
republican
uh city a very conservative city
right we still have you know some
liberals and
a lot of the younger population the
younger cuban cuban americans
and the ones that are are coming into
the country now
they're they're a little bit more
moderate a lot more progressive
so there's a divide so the older the
older people are more conservative the
younger
people more liberal absolutely but
that's that's sort of everywhere isn't
it
yeah to some degree exactly exactly
there's uh bars on the windows
in some places right why i mean theft uh
well remember uh you came from a country
that was predominantly
uh communist or excuse me a communist
country right
where people you know they tried to
protect anything that they had so you
know i
i guess that's that's you know part of
the cuban uh how can i say psychology
yeah the psychology i want to protect
what's mine
yeah i want to keep what's mine i don't
want anybody to interfere with me
and take what's mine and uh i guess
that's a little bit of a psyche
a little bit of the cuban psyche so it's
it in a way it's this uh
it's this american dream that a lot of
people can't get
okay it's i've been i've been here five
hours so i don't i know nothing
i'll admit that i know nothing but i'm
seeing like this
you know everyone's got a house a little
yard right
and these are all homeowners mostly are
they renting
yeah yeah you know you got a mix just
like any other place in america you got
people renting
but yeah this is you know this is the
american dream
people in cuba don't have that ability
to to purchase
a home uh that they know that
the government can't take away from them
uh you know they come here with that
with that aspiration
right and they fight for for what they
believe in and
yeah you have a lot of hard-working
families you know cuban people
will tell you that they built up hialeah
you know
um dude would you consider them
patriotic towards the states here
yes all towards the state towards the us
or towards the u.s like are they
patriotic americans absolutely
absolutely they love the united states
you gotta remember
the united states gave them an
opportunity at life
uh they gave them a shot that they were
never gonna have in their country
you know they came here with you know
sometimes
nothing you know right or maybe a few
dollars in their pocket
and this country gave them that
opportunity that they really wanted
and they made the best of that
opportunity and this is
a result of that hard work okay
so what's going on in the community now
i mean you're one man's perspective
right i'm i know nothing
so the guys this is no authoritative
piece on uh
documentary let's say on hialeah these
are a couple perspectives
take it for what it is there's all sorts
of stories and angles
and a bus that's about to hit us
nice bus new buses
you know unemployment is low in hialeah
um
as you were able to see uh even people
who don't speak the language people who
don't speak english
have a job um yeah that's interesting
all these shops a lot of people don't
speak english yeah
it's just total it's its own ecosystem
it feels like a separate country almost
absolutely yeah and we are you know this
is a bubble
where if you are a non-english speaker
you know i encourage everybody i teach i
teach uh
students english you know adults and
recently arrived children
i teach them english and i certainly
encourage everybody to learn the
language
right but if you are you know in a pinch
and you're looking for a job
you can certainly find something and you
can definitely work without knowing the
language you know it's not a barrier to
entry
by any means they keep their place very
tidy
oh yeah good job yeah cuban people not
that it's not my people but
is that a trait of cubans they keep
things extra clean
yeah yeah i didn't know that remember
what i said they they
like to protect the stairs you know they
fought hard for what they had
right make sure that they take care of
it
she's on it place looks very nice
bonito did i say that right bonito
beautiful
see yeah you said that right yeah
beautiful she didn't understand my
english
and she didn't understand spanish either
yes my accent she said
once you said something in english and
she just shut it off yeah i knew it
right
now but again it proves my point you
know
you saw the home that she's living in
she's more than certainly retired which
means that she
she lived here for a long time uh she
made a living
and she doesn't even speak the language
and she has a decent home you know
right the envy of many people many
people would love to have a home like
that
and again that's what you're going to
find in hialeah you're going to find a
lot of hard-working people
who came here just for an opportunity so
essentially
hard-working people very patriotic about
america
she doesn't speak any english none at
all
but she loves her country that being
america you saw the flag
yeah that's cool are there any homeless
here
i haven't seen anyone uh
sleeping on the streets on benches or
anything i think you may
you know there may be a handful around
the the entire city of
quarter million you don't really see
them they're not
no there's no vagrance there's no
homeless around why
is it because the family structure
strong enough for most
people or what's the deal um
i don't that's a good question i've
never thought about that or you have
social services set up
for them yeah i mean you have the same
social services that you have in other
parts of the uh
or it's just a bad place to be homeless
like nobody's gonna give you money here
maybe
i think i think that's more there's no
sympathy on that there's no sympathy
like
we left we love communist cuba
go do do whatever but don't ask me for
that yeah they're more than likely to
tell you
you know hey you have two feet you have
two hands
right you know do something for yourself
uh
but it can work you know what immigrants
very much many of the times have such an
advantage because you've seen
you're not an immigrant but i'm just
saying your family extended family or
the people that come here
they have something to compare against
and they can see
things that us americans that grew up
here might not be able to see
absolutely i think you're 100 correct
and i think one of the advantages
is that an immigrant is more than likely
to take a risk
than a natural american or an um right
has nothing
has nothing to lose maybe right they
have nothing to lose everything to gain
so you see a lot of people who
have no family here just uh came in from
cuba
and within five years they set up a
business i know that that was the case
with my cousin's friend and my cousin
they both set up businesses
right he had no family uh and he set up
a business
uh putting up awnings you know he bought
a house
he bought a second house he had cars and
he
he put his pennies together working odds
and ends
and doing small jobs and he was able to
do all that
within a few years but i think the
average american is very scared to take
that risk and invest that money
just to have it uh not succeed right
right and so if you if you if you left
your country that's a huge risk to begin
with a
right you go to a new place you don't
have anything set up there's
you actually have no option but then to
take risk right
you know much of the times right you
sort of have to uh yeah like if you if
you want to
move on with your life it's it's a leap
of blind faith they came here without
anything in their pocket
uh and you know since they're successful
with that
first jump or for that first leap of
faith yep
they're more than likely to do it again
and again and again and
that's why you see a lot of successful
people all right guys you have anything
else to say
that's it that's that's the story that's
the story of hialeah
carlos saved this video with great
insight and
information i had nothing on that front
since i'm a rookie here
but it's been an interesting day hope
you guys got some of that
i mean overall it's just wide spaced out
streets
nice mostly nicely taken care of homes
and shopping centers but there's a good
communal feel here
it feels safe it's clean again i'm a
rookie here
i'm sure there's all sorts of darkness
that takes place this isn't a propaganda
piece but overall really cool strongly
suggest coming here
just for a meal if you're in miami get
out to hialeah
it's almost a little bit like traveling
to another country
a little bit a little bit if you're not
a spanish speaker like myself
it's like got this exotic to it
all right guys thanks for coming along
until the next one
there we go look at this guy's rocking
it
he's uh quite expressive in his style
he's got the g wagon going and the
american flag
it's a new house